i've got a two by two matrix here and
let's just say it's entries are a
b
c
and d
and it's composed of two column vectors
we've done this before let's call this
first column
v one and let's call the second column
v2
so we can rewrite it here we could say
v1 is equal to
ac
and we could write that
v2 is equal to b
d
and these are both members of r2 and
just to have a nice visualization in our
head let's graph these two
so let me draw my axes
that's my vertical axis
that's my horizontal axis and maybe v1
looks something like this v1 might look
something like that
so that is v1 its
horizontal component will be a its
vertical coordinate if you view this as
maybe a position vector or where you're
going to however just how we're drawing
it is c and then v2 let's just say it
looks something like this
let's say that they're not the same
vector so v2 looks like that
v2 its
horizontal coordinate is going to be b
and its vertical coordinate is going to
be
d
now what we're going to concern
ourselves with in this video is the
parallelogram generated by these two
guys what i mean by that is imagine that
these two guys are position vectors that
are specifying points on a parallelogram
and then of course the zero or not of
course but
the origin is also another point on the
parallelogram so what will be the last
point on the parallelogram well you can
imagine a parallelogram we already have
two sides of it so
the other two sides have to be parallel
so one side will look like that
it's parallel to v1 the way i've drawn
it and then the other side will look
like this
that's our parallelogram the
parallelogram generated by v2 and v1
we're going to concern ourselves with
specifically is the area
the area
of
the parallelogram parallelogram
generated by v1 and v2 so how do we
figure that out
so in general if i have just any
parallelogram this is kind of a tilted
one but if i just have any parallelogram
let me just draw any parallelogram right
there
the area the area is just equal to
the base so that could be the base
times the height
times the height so it's equal to base
i'll write capital b since we have a
lowercase b there base times height
that's what the area of a parallelogram
would be now what are the base and the
height in this situation
so let me write this down
the area of our parallelogram is equal
to
the base times
the height and actually well let me just
write it here so what is the base here
the base here is going to be the length
of
this right of our vector v so this is
our base
so this right here is going to be the
length of
vector v1
the length of this orange vector right
here and what's the height of this
parallelogram going to be
so we could drop a perpendicular here
we could drop a perpendicular here and
that the length of this line right here
is going to be our height
so how can we figure out that you know
we know what v1 is so we can figure out
the base pretty easily but how can we
figure out how can we figure out the
height
well one thing we can do is if we can
figure out
this guy right here if we can figure out
this guy we could use a pythagorean
theorem because the length of this
vector plus squared plus
the h plus h squared is going to be
equal to the length of v2 squared
so let's see if we can do that what is
this guy what is this green guy right
here
well if you imagine a line
let's imagine some line l
so let's say l
is a line
spanned by v1 spanned
by
v1 which means you take all of the
multiples of v1 and all of the positions
that they specify will create a set of
points and that is my line l so you take
all the multiples of v1 you're going to
get every point along this line along a
line that's like that
now if we have l defined that way that
line right there is l i don't know if
you can see it let me do it a little bit
better and it goes through v1 and it
just keeps going over there what is this
green line right there
this green line that we're concerned
with that's the projection that is the
projection
onto l of what
well we have a perpendicular here you
can imagine a light source coming down i
don't know if that analogy helps you but
it's kind of the shadow of v2 onto that
line so it's a projection of v2
of your vector v2 onto l is this green
line right there
so if we want to figure out h
if we want to figure out h we can just
use the pythagorean theorem so we can
say
that the length of h squared or we could
just write well i'm just writing h as
the length i'm not even specifying as a
vector so we could say that h squared
a squared where that is the length of
this line
plus
the length of this vector squared and
the length of that vector squared is the
length of the projection onto l of v 2.
do that and i'll do it in the different
color so the length
of
the projection
onto l
of v2
squared right we're just doing the
pythagorean theorem this squared plus
the square is going to equal that
squared it's going to be equal to it's
going to be equal to
the length of v2
squared that's just pythagorean theorem
pythagorean
theorem nothing fancy there theorem
so how can we simplify we want to figure
out we want to solve for h and actually
just let's just solve for h squared for
now because it'll keep things a little
bit simpler so we can say that h squared
h squared is equal to
this guy it's equal to the length of my
vector v2 squared minus the length of
the projection squared so minus i'll do
that in purple minus the length of the
projection
the projection onto l
of v 2 squared remember this thing is
just this thing right here we're just
doing the pythagorean theorem so let's
see if we can simplify this or write it
in terms that we understand so v2 is the
length of a vector squared this is just
equal to let me write it this way this
is just equal to
v2
dot v2 you take a vector you dot it with
itself and you get the length of that
vector squared we saw that many many
videos ago
and then what is this guy going to be
equal to
well the projection i'll do it over here
the projection
onto l of v2 is going to be equal to
v2 dot the spy spanning vector which is
v1
so it's v2
dot v1
over the spanning vector dotted with
itself v1
dot v1 we saw this several videos ago
when we learned about projections and
this is just a number this is just a
number right there and then it's going
to be times the spanning vector itself
so times v1
that is what the projection is so it's
going to be
this
minus the projection the length of the
projection squared so what is the length
of the projection squared well that's
this guy
dotted with himself this guy dotted with
himself let me write it this way let me
take it let me take it step by step so
this is going to be minus
minus i want to make sure i can still
see that up there so i don't have to
redo write it
minus the projection is going to be it
looks a little complicated but hopefully
things will simplify v2 dot
v1
over v1
dot v1
times
switch colors times the vector this is
all just going to end up being a number
remember you take dot products you get
numbers times the vector v1 and we're
going to take the length of that whole
thing
we're going to take the length of that
whole thing squared and all of this is
going to be equal to
h squared once again just the
pythagorean theorem this or this squared
which is the height squared
is equal to your hypotenuse squared this
is your hypotenuse squared minus the
other side squared this is the other
side squared it looks a little
complicated but just the projection of
this guy onto that right there so let's
see if we can simplify this a little bit
we're just going to have to break out
some algebra or let's see what we can do
here well actually not algebra some
linear algebra so what is this guy well
this guy is just the dot product of this
with itself
so this is just equal to
we know i mean any vector if you take
the square of its length it's just that
vector dotted with itself so this thing
if we're taking the square of this guy's
length it's just equal to this guy
dotted with himself
so let me write everything over again so
we get h squared
h squared is equal to
v2
dot v2
and then
minus this guy dotted with himself so
minus
v2
dot v1
over v1
times the vector
v1
dotted with itself
dotted with it
dotted with v2
dot v1 remember this green part is just
a number over v1 dot v1
times
v1
and what is this equal to let's just
simplify this
these are just scalar quantities and we
saw that the dot product is associative
with respect to scalar quantity so we
can just change the order here so this
is going to be equal to the scalar
quantity times itself so as we could say
this is equal to
v2 v2
dot
v1
let me write it this way v2 dot v1
that's going to be and we're going to
multiply the numerator times itself v2
dot v1
and then all of that
over
v1 dot v1
times v1
dot v1 remember i'm just taking these
two terms and multiplying them by each
other i'm just switching the order
because and then we know that the
scalars can kind of be taken out
times these two guys dot each other
times
v1 dot v1 that's what this simplifies to
now this is now a number we had vectors
here but when you take the dot product
you just get a number and this number is
the same as this number so we can
simplify a little bit so we can cross
those two guys out and then we are left
with
we are left with that our height squared
our height squared is equal to it's
equal to this expression times itself
right we have it times itself twice so
it's equal to well let me start over
here it's equal to v2 dot v2
v2
dot v2
minus
this guy times itself so
v2
dot v1
squared
all of that over just one of these guys
v1
dot
v1 that is what the height squared is
now we have the height square we could
take the square root if we just want to
solve for the height but to keep our mat
simple to keep our mat simple we know
that area is equal to base times height
let's just say what the area squared is
equal to because then both of these
terms will get squared so we know that
the so if the area is equal to base
times height
so the beginning of the video then the
area squared is going to be equal to
these two guys squared it's going to be
equal to base squared times height
squared
now what is the base squared let me do
it like this
so the base squared
we already saw the base of our
parallelogram is the length
the base of our entire parallelogram
remember this is the parallelogram in
question the base is the length of
vector v1
now what is the base squared the base
squared is going to be the length of
vector v1
squared or another way of writing that
is v1
dot
v1
and we already know what the height
squared is it's this expression right
there
right let me write that down the height
squared is the height squared right
there so what is our area squared going
to be
our area squared
our area squared let me go down here
while i have more space
our area squared is going to be equal to
our base squared which is
v1
dot
v1 times our height squared
times
times let me write it like this
no i was using the wrong color
times this guy over here v2
dot
v2
minus
dot v1
squared
over
v1
dot
now what does this simplify to well this
is just a number these are all just
numbers so if i multiply if i distribute
this out this is equal to what
this times this is equal to
v1 let me write it color coded v1 dot v1
times this guy
times
v2
dot v2
and then when i multiply this guy times
that guy what happens well i have this
guy in the numerator and that guy in the
denominator so they cancel out so i'm
just left with
minus
v2
dot
v1
squared
now let's remind ourselves what these
two vectors were
v1 was the vector ac and v2 is the
vector bd let me rewrite it down here so
we have it to work with
so v1
was equal to the vector ac
and v2
is equal to the vector
b
d
so what is v one dot v one what is v one
dot v one
that is equal to
that is equal to a dot a which is or a
times a a squared plus c squared that's
this right there and that's what's v2
dot v2 so we're going to have that
times v2 dot v2
v2 dot v2 is v squared plus d squared
and then we're going to have minus
v2
dot v1 squared so what's v2
dot v1
it is what's b times a plus d times c or
a times b plus we're just dotting these
two guys so it's a b
plus
c d
and then we're squaring it we're
squaring in let's see what this
simplifies to hopefully it simplifies to
something
let me switch colors so if we just
multiply this out let me write it here
our area squared is equal to a squared
times b squared a squared
b squared a squared times d squared plus
a squared times d squared plus c squared
times b squared plus c squared
times b squared plus c squared times d
squared plus c squared times d squared
and then minus
this guy squared
what is that going to be equal to a b
squared is a squared b squared and then
i have i'm going to multiply these guys
times each other twice so it's going to
be
plus
a b c d and then you're going to have a
c squared d squared i just foiled this
out that's the best way you could kind
of think about it
and then if i distribute this negative
sign what do i have let me rewrite
everything it's equal to a squared b
squared plus a squared d squared
plus c squared b squared plus
c squared d squared
minus
a squared b squared
minus 2 a b
c d
minus c squared d squared all i did is i
distributed the minus sign
now it looks like some things will
simplify nicely and remember all of this
was equal to our area squared we have an
a b squared we have a minus a b squared
they cancel out
we have a c d a minus c d squared and a
c d squared so they cancel out so all
we're left with is that the area of our
parallelogram squared
is equal to
a squared d squared
minus
2 a b
c d
plus
c
c squared
plus c squared
b squared
c squared
b squared now this might look a little
bit bizarre to you but you might well if
you made a substitution right here if
you said that x
is equal to
a d and if you said y is equal to
c b then what does this become this is
equal to this is equal to x squared
minus 2 times x y
plus y squared right hopefully you
recognize this and this is just the same
thing as
x minus y
squared
so if we this was our substitutions we
made i did this just so you can
visualize this a little bit better
so we have our area squared
is equal to
x minus y squared or ad
80 minus cb or let me write it b
c
squared that's what the area of our
parallelogram squared is
and if you want to you know if you don't
quite understand what i did here i just
made these substitutions so you can
recognize it better but just to
understand that this is the same thing
as this if you want you can just
multiply this guy out and you'll get
that right there but what is this
what is this
what is this thing right here it's the
determinant this is the determinant of
our original matrix
of our original matrix up here
well i call that matrix a and then i use
the i used a again for area so let me
write it this way
area squared let me write it like this
area
area squared
area squared is equal to ad minus bc
squared this is so this is area
this is our area these a's are all area
but what is this this is the determinant
of my matrix that is the determinant of
that is the determinant
of my matrix a my original matrix that i
started the problem with which is equal
to the determinant of a
b
c d right the determinant of this is a d
minus bc
by definition
so your area
this is exciting the area squared so the
area of your parallelogram squared is
equal to the determinant of the matrix
whose column vectors construct that
parallelogram is equal to the
determinant
of your matrix squared or if you take
the square root of both sides you get
the area
is equal to the absolute value of the
determinant of a which is a pretty neat
outcome especially considering how much
hairy algebra we had to go through let's
go back all the way over here go back to
the drawing so if we want to
figure out the area
of
this parallelogram right here that is
defined or that is created by the two
column vectors
of a matrix we literally just have to
find the the determinant of the matrix
the area of this
the area is equal to the absolute value
of the determinant of a and you have to
do that because this might be negative
if you as you could imagine if you kind
of swapped these guys around if you swap
some of the rows this guy would be
negative but you can't have a negative
area and it wouldn't really change the
definition it really wouldn't change
what spanned if you switch v1 and v2
you're still spanning the same
parallelogram you just might get the
negative of the determinant
but that is a really neat outcome and
you know when you first learn
determinants in in school i mean we we
learned the the first motivation for
determinant was this idea of well you
know when we take the inverse of a two
by two this thing shows up in the
denominator we call that the determinant
but now there's this other
interpretation here that's actually the
area of the parallelogram created by the
column vectors of this matrix